[Music]
name's rooster we're going on a trip
really we're going in the car so many
smells I have never smelled before my
nose so confused
hello I'm Duke and you are hey cow Moo
you're a cow you're supposed to dog I'm
gonna get my tail like an idiot are you
to throw ball oh please little ball and
I will change it because my brain is the
size of a rat turd okay yeah I get it
you big boy
[Music]
the separate life effects - yeah you got
the jump on me yeah see I couldn't see
him because of the cone then get rid of
the cone man I would I would but my
therapist I need it it's a medical
device he's doctor yeah you're cured
hallelujah what you're about to hear is
the most dramatic thing you ever heard
in your whole life do any of you know
captain snowball yeah yeah yes yes we do
and here we go
my name is Daisy and I really gotta talk
to him I don't mean to sound dramatic
but a poor defenseless animal needs
saving
I need captive snowball for
all right well I gotta go but nice
meeting you uh what was it again okay
you don't listen it's Daisy whatever
okay I got to get to do to get stuff to
do not in any way no let's free that
tiger probably you huh you're wearing
the bright suit everyone's gonna notice
you I'll be fine
[Music]
Oh
here's that good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing I'm doing superhero stuff this
meaning of the superhero animal friends
to order come on Molly
time to go I'm gonna be late for school
captain snowball you're in charge while
I'm gone
one first of all I want to welcome white
thunder back from the washing machine
who was put in there with a red blanket
and hates fourth will be known as pink
thunder personally I like the new look
[Music]
let's say we go for a walk first time
here yeah dr. Francis is the best
veterinarian in that business you're
gonna love him he specializes in
behavioral disorders but I don't have a
behavioral disorder I'm fine too it's by
human that's nuts
I mean you know I I bring a dead bird
she throws it out I bring him a dead
mouse garbage and I've gone no no my
owner always says you're such a good dog
and I feel like a good dog
what if deep down I'm a bad dog I'm a
bad dog we start fires
that was weird sister it's gonna get way
weirder why is there lampshade on your
head my owner might have given me a
little bit a cat oh okay do you hear
that
oh you're pouring oh I wonder what other
sounds I could make
[Music]
tail ears whoa whoa whoa hold on now you
gotta learn how to act like a cat I'm
gonna throw some situations at you and
you're just gonna react like a cat no
punching is for dopes you're above the
fact of life in the face okay
search his butt to the cop walk on
keyboard there you go
coffee on computer and down yes you got
it you're as close to a cat as the dog
can get the secret life of fish to eat
sweet pea what cats eat birds you're
seriously gonna make are you sweet Pete
[Music]
no bad dog bad cat dog sorry
[Music]